François baayrou est le grand témoin de
64 minutes bonsoir François bairou merci
d'être avec nous sur TV5 Monde vous êtes
le maire de la ville de peau dans le sud
de la France vous êtes le président du
Mouvement Démocrate formation centriste
vous avez été ministre français de
l'Éducation nationale pendant plus de 4
ans commençons si vous le voulez bien
par la politique internationale François
Baayou on l'annoncait à l'instant dans
le rappel des titres le sommet de Minsk
vient t juste de débuter il se tient
donc en Biélorussie il y a un an jour
pour jour débutait le mouvement de
contestation en Ukraine il a très vite
viré à la guerre civile dans l'est de ce
pays qui est au portes de l'Europe c'est
clairement un échec pour la diplomatie
européenne non François Baayou ben
aujourd'hui en tout cas on peut dire que
c'est à
l'initiative de deux diplomaties
européennes la diplomatie française et
la diplomatie
allemande que se tient le sommet que
tout le monde dit de la dernière chance
h je pense qu'il l' d'une certaine
manière et donc on voit que lorsque des
pays européens la France et l'Allemagne
on aurait pu souhaiter que ce soit
l'ensemble des pays européens qui pèse
dans le même sens mais au moins la
France et l'Allemagne sont-elles à
l'initiative et on voit que lorsque
c'est le cas et bien elles sont
entendues en tout cas qu'elle crée une
dynamique on ne sait pas encore si cette
dynamique va pouvoir déboucher sur la la
paix ou en tout cas sur un un mouvement
en direction de la paix de la
coopération et de la vie en commun mais
c'est déjà un point dont on doit dire
que la diplomatie française et la
diplomatie allemande le président de la
République et la chancelière allemande
doivent être crédité alors François
Baayou les sanctions européenne jusque-
là et américaine ont eu un impact sur
l'économie russe mais soyons clair elles
n'ont pas eu d'effet politiques on voit
le résultat n'est-il pas le temps selon
vous n'est-il pas venu le temps selon
vous de de dialoguer avec le président
russe Vladimir Poutine qui est
d'ailleurs présent à Minsk alors vous
dites elles n'ont eu aucun effet je ne
crois pas je pense qu'elles ont eu un
effet et que cet effet
le le le trouble qui s'est emparé de
l'économie russe sont un élément pour
que Vladimir Poutine entende je pense
qu'elles ont eu un effet même très
important mais est-ce qu'il est temps de
dialoguer avec la Russie oui je pense
qu'il est temps et je pense que la
vocation de l'Union européenne et la
vocation de la Russie sont de vivre
ensemble ces deux grands ensembles
géographiques et politiques
oui il est temps qu'ils vivent ensemble
parce que rien dans la vocation de
l'Union européenne et de la Russie ne
devrait les pousser à être l'une contre
l'autre je pense qu'il y a un point très
important c'est que Vladimir Poutine
comprennent
que l'Union européenne ça n'est pas un
empire comme l'Union soviétique était un
empire que l'Europe n'a aucune vocation
à la domination et que même l'esprit de
création de
l'Europe c'est un esprit au contraire de
coopération entre ses membres et une
volonté pacifique à l'extérieur s'il y a
eu dans l'histoire des
hommes un ensemble qui ne soit pas un
ensemble impérialiste comme on disait
euh qui n'est pas vocation à la
domination qui soit au contraire fait
pour que euh les nations et les êtres
humains essaient autant que possible de
coopérer et de travailler ensemble sauf
que vous le savez franç pardon de couper
il y a l'OTAN et que le président
Poutine dit l'Union européenne non mais
l'OTAN euh se rapproche sans cesse de de
nos frontières si vous voulez je le on
peut avoir des discussions à propos de
l'OT temp vous savez que j'étais opposé
au fait que la France rejoigne le
commandement intégré de l'OTAN je pense
que ça a été une décision peu réfléchie
et qui ne nous a pas apporté grand-chose
euh et qui parfois peut au contraire
donner lieu à des ambiguïés et quand on
en a eu besoin par exemple on est allé
au Mali on est allé au Mali seul donc
euh
donc je pense que il faut simplement que
l'Union européenne transmette à la
Russie le message que notre vocation euh
autant ou pas autant c'est la paix que
c'est pour cela que nous nous sommes
formés en Union européenne c'est pour
cela que nous avons fait ce choix
incroyable historiquement quelques mois
à peine parce que c'est 5 10 ans
seulement donc c'est quelques mois après
la fin de la guerre de décider non pas
qu'on allait vivre les uns à côté des
autres en paix mais que nous allons
vivre ensemble ce qui est pas du tout la
même chose et et que sur tous les plan
essentiel de l'énergie des matières
premières et puis ensuite du marché et
puis de la coopération économique et
puis de la monnaie nous allions vivre
ensemble vous avez cité François baayrou
le Mali l'armée française est en effet
engagée dans ce pays vous disiez seul il
y a aussi la Centrafrique il y a l'Irak
également est-ce que ce n'est pas
trop dans un monde idéal oui c'est trop
mais dans le monde comme il est il y a
très très peu de pays dans le monde il y
a très très peu depis dans le monde qui
est une capacité de projection militaire
qui puisse non pas seulement employer
des mots mais avoir des actes c'est ce
qui fait le la place tout à fait
singulière de la France dans le concert
du monde et c'est une des raisons pour
lesquelles il est justifié que nous
soyons au Conseil de sécurité des
Nations unies et donc pour moi en tout
cas le le le ce fait là nous donne une
responsabilité qui fait que que dans les
grandes affaires qui sont traitées là
nous devons intervenir et d'abord
intervenir parce que peut-être nous
étions intervenus de manière peu
réfléchi et désordonné dans d'autres
conflits comme la Libye la France
intervient également dans dans la
coalition internationale engagé contre
le groupe état islamique en Irak et en
Syrie on a le sentiment François Baayou
que c'est un éternel recommencement et
que l'on revu la que l'on revu la guerre
contre le terrorisme qu'avait lancé
George Bou je crois que ça n'a rien à
voir je pense que la décision de buouch
avait été une
décision qui n'était pas maîtrisée et
qui n'était pas pensé comme il fallait
qu'elle a été cette décision créatrice
de grand
désordre raison pour laquelle j'avais
soutenu Jacques
Chirac bien
qu'étant dans une relation un peu
d'opposition politique intérieure avec
lui mais j'ai j'étais monté à la tribune
pour le soutenir quand il a décidé quand
il a euh dit que la France ne
participerait pas et qu'au contraire il
a dit non à cet enchaînement à
l'intervention militaire en Irak à cet
enchaînement et donc euh le le
le je pense que c'est une guerre à
recommencer toujours c'est un conflit
mais qui dép pas de notre fête euh
la volonté de groupe euh qui sont
politico-rigieux euh d'introduire la loi
euh une loi
théocratique euh
dictatorial sur les sociétés et sur les
êtres humains et donc de menacer par la
même tout ce à quoi nous croyons et tout
ce à quoi euh croient les peuples du
monde euh ça nous met devant nos
responsabilités vous comprenez c'est
c'est pour ça que la France c'est pas
absolument n'importe quel pays parce que
les autres pays ils se contentent en
règle générale d'avoir des protestations
verbales la France c'est un pays qui
intervient et Dieu sait que ce n'est pas
facile
d'intervenir je suis vous l'aviez
rappelé le maire de poau comme vous
savez c'est une des bases militaires les
plus importantes que la France possède
et il y a des soldats qui sont en
garnison à poau qui sont engagés sur
tous les théâtres d'opérations que vous
avez indiqué po c'est la plus grande
base d'hélicoptère au monde
d'hélicoptère en Europe excusez-moi la
plus grande base d'hélicoptère militaire
en Europe et donc chaque fois que dans
le monde il faut
intervenir naturellement les militaires
sont concernés et naturellement les
risques et les victimes sont chez nous
alors intervenir à l'étranger sur des
théâtres de guerre ce n'est pas non plus
sans conséquence François Baayou les
auteurs des attentats de Paris se sont
revendiqués de l'organisation état
islamique ou encore d'alkaaïda au Yémen
ils étaient néanmoins français j'en
viens à une situation beaucoup plus
intérieure selon vous de quoi est-ce le
symptôme le problème est-il vraiment au
Moyen-Orient ou aussi en France euh le
problème est dans le monde d'abord pas
seulement chez nous ou en Occident le
problème est dans le monde le le le fait
que la violence euh soit considérée
désormais comme une arme normale euh de
premier recours et que cette violence
prenne ce tour absolument euh horrible
horrifique bar bar que nous
voyons dans chacune des vidéos de ces
groupes qui revendiquent la mort d'un
otage vous avez vu on brûle vif un
pilote pourtant qu'il a la même religion
que la vôtre si c'était un argument
qu'on pouvait avancer pourquoi des
jeunes Belges des jeunes français des
jeunes Canadiens des jeunes Britanniques
des jeunes nlandaisj ces groupes un des
symptômes du caractère déstabilisé des
sociétés dans lesquelles nous vivons
c'est que la folie devient une
fascination pour des
esprits déstabilisés
tourneboulés la folie et la folie
intégriste si du moins ils savent ce que
c'est et la folie barbare devient une
fascination il y a une chose
permettez-moi de le dire je vais le dire
avec beaucoup de
prudence il y a une chose qui
est lourde dans ces gestes faits au nom
de la religion c'est la fascination de
la mort il disent nous nous sommes
au-dessus de toute menace parce que nous
non seulement nous ne craignons pas la
mort mais nous la voulons et
euh ce sentiment de fascination pour la
mort c'est le contraire de notre société
et de notre civilisation nous nous
sommes euh la civilisation et les
peuples qui au contraire HM avons dès
l'origine choisi la vie h la vie en
liberté le respect de l'autre euh la vie
de l'autre et la vie de soi-même Fran le
respect l'égalité peut-être aussi vous
aviez dit il y a plusieurs années
attention aux divisions avant la
dernière présidentielle attention aux
divisions qui minent la société
française vous avez été l'un des rares
politiques à insister précisément sur
cette notion on a vu l'élan de
solidarité le grand rassemblement du 11
janvier cet esprit d'unité le Premier
ministre manuel Vals a parlé d'aparteide
là encore j'insiste permettez-moi quel
est le malaise pourquoi est-ce
qu'aujourd'hui en France on étiquette
les gens en fonction de leur
appartenance religieuse communautaire qu
une il faut il faut voir ça vous êtes en
train de
décrire une conséquence comme si c'était
une cause un symptôme comme si c'était
le mal le la maladie elle est très
simple et très claire la maladie c'est
que une société dans laquelle un très
grand nombre de nos enfants de toute
origine ne trouvent pas leur place c'est
une société qui entraîne à toutes ces
dérives là alors pourquoi ell trouvent
pas leur place pour au moins deux
raisons qui sont l'une et l'autre qui
suffiraiit à elle-même la première c'est
que notre système
éducatif a perdu
euh la clé H qui était celle de
l'intégration et de tu peux réussir d'où
que tu viennes mite première explication
deuxè c'est que notre économie est si
malade que l'emploi et là c'est devenu
beaucoup plus rare que le chômage y est
galopant et ça n'est en rien une
malédiction je vous donne un chiffre qui
est sorti
hier
l'Allemagne a réalisé
217 milliards d'excédents elle a fait un
bénéfice comme pays de 217 milliards
d'euros d'excédent commercial tandis que
la France elle a un déficit de plus de
50 milliards et si on regarde bien les
chiffres ce déficit là il s'arrange pas
il se creuse parce que le pétrole a
baissé donc ça nous améliore les comptes
mais ça ne change rien à la réalité de
notre difficultés à produire et à
commercialiser François bairou merci
beaucoup d'avoir accepté de témoigner
dans 64 minutes le monde en français sur
TV5 Mo je rappelle donc que vous êtes le
maire de peau dans les Pyrénées
Atlantiques 64 comme le nom de notre
journal Merci à VOUS François Baou c'est
pour ça que vous êtes venu Merci à VOUS
euh et vous avez d'ailleurs réagi sur
les réseaux sociaux hein sur la
disparition de Roger annin où vous dites
il a eu avec la ville de poau une
histoire chaleureuse et riche avec
notamment ce festival de théâtre qu'il
avait créé dans la ville que vous
administré ben justement on va rendre
hommage à ce comédien le mum d'Alger qui
nous a quitté à 89 ans on se souvient
notamment du coup de Siroco l'un des
acteurs français les plus populaire
Aujan